It's crazy, San Diego is so crowded during Comic Con,
there isn't a hotel room available anywhere in the city
for miles around.
It's nuts.
Yeah, it's crazy.
And I actually, because space is so tight,
I came up with a way to make a little money while I'm here.
Seriously, Andy, I'm just curious, what's that?
Well, I'm Airbnb-ing my lectern.
(audience cheers)
Say hi to Hans everybody.
[Hans] Hey.
Say hi, Hans.
His name's Hans, huh?
Yeah, yeah, it's Hans down there.
So, I'm curious.
How are you doing there, Hans?
[Hans] I can't feel my legs.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay, okay.
That's fine, leave it alone.
No, you're just, you be quiet for the next hour
down there Hans.
(audience claps)
He'll probably pass out soon.
Yeah.